so i i start by saying that a good
friend of mine from oxford said if
you're not a native english speaker
start all of your presentation by
making fun of the friends so pardon my
english
and now every mistake i make is fine um
right so for the record uh i will add on
top of it before i start that it's you
know it's a bit hard to go and do
presentations after like those people
and so i have a high standard so i try
to
match the
the quality level and but i don't
promise anything so you know
have fun so
you had a businessy like presentation
really a really mass presentation which
i personally really enjoyed and now
you'll have the short let's do it staff
engineering project a or presentation
and we can do it like computer sciencey
and get entertained stuff etc but it's
like 8 30 so no
yeah so if you want and we have a paper
and we have like the presentation in
youtube but now we will have the quick
funny a nice presentation stuff so
subtract the sub a subset-based strategy
for fast forward to ml because any good
computer science paper needs to start in
this formula called name dot and
unclear name
and so formula achieved next a agenda
quickly so what is automl and why we
what is cool or background a why is
there not a member's heart of prominent
definition a smaller database can solve
c
solutions motivation our super cool
approach the subtract solution and
resultant conclusions are basically
results and conclusions
it's straightforward guys
uh the obvious slide of narcissism
actually my previous presenters didn't
have one and i'm really disappointed a
post doctor on ucl cto and data club we
are doing cool a life science algorithm
development so if you need one a
be fully booked so in a few months time
a phd involved in mathematics it's like
mathematics but which cancer and
doing too much coding recently like 10
years time
yeah
cool so this is right into interesting
stuff so what is optimal and why it's
cool
in your head do you familiar with
autumnal
okay great
how many how many of you actually use an
autumnal in your work
thank you thank you
and the last question do you actually
develop your own otemo
okay great this is the right answer no
don't do it it's a good idea hey i'll
tell you in a second why so autumnal is
really cool and actually you should
develop automotives or at least use them
so i don't like when non-technical
people do it because they're just like
oh we have super cool stuff we put in
some data here and getting a model and
now we don't know what to do
actually the first presentation was
actually about that i think hey
at least i get the point from that
um so
in this room when you actually
understanding why autumnal is hard and
all the it's invited you actually
understand how to take the solution of
the automl and actually
make your extra personal adjustments to
make it happen really so
i think it's fine that we understand in
automobile is cool a few um frameworks i
want to address now before i continue a
auto sqlm
anyone
no
so autoscaling is an a library for
python actually wrapping the sql
scikit-learn secondland library and it
uses really really cool stuff the first
version was cool the second version was
cooler nobody used it i don't know why
yeah personally i like it and another a
library we used in this research is
teapot
anyone
right tibot is an another autumnal
library actually using a genetic
algorithm type of algorithm
if you don't familiar with genetic
algorithm shame of you
if you do great uh i don't speak about
it right now but it's basically getting
motivation of
how evolution works and applying it to
searching direct searching solutions uh
personally my favorite type of
algorithms
uh so now when we know it
uh actually i find really cute a
troubled defense a
like presentation and
and
they'll actually use two automotive
stuff basically ask you lan and teapot
yeah because these are the best and
compared to 15 people like you
like randomly at least they say so we
don't really know them so we believe
them and they found out on classical
data from cargill that's four out of the
times autumn always three-time styles
and one time is human win so i bought
the ties i was actually really
interesting about the ties
so apparently
when you're looking about the
able solutions of otml and machine
learning done by people
it's a sometimes we just hit the same
optima
and then we get a tie
okay so from this statistics you can
actually say that automobile is really
really good nowadays don't take it don't
take it as a grounded don't use it like
it's a magic box and you can use it
anytime because it's actually
not really easy
so
automl is comp a compute intensive
leading to relatively long distribution
time so even like the naive optimal is
just like you can like develop it for
yourself in 30 seconds let's take all
the machine learning models in sqlm take
all the high performance hyper parameter
optimization techniques that we know
take all the feature selection
techniques that we know put them in the
pipeline try all of them on your data
which is a good idea if you have like
super big computers uh and you don't not
that big at least
uh so optimal is hard even if you try
the naive approach it's hard if you take
any more fancy approaches like meta
learning
a search engine direction depot autofill
etc it's still really really expensive
to run it on real data
okay
because you need to try and train a lot
of photo of the ml pipelines
each time so it's expensive
so it's not that easy now model
selection is limited to predefined
structure
it's an issue so
it doesn't just try all the
configurations so you as a person can
say okay take these and these models and
they have like a cool assemble which
other stuff or even non-machine learning
models and it can be a really good idea
and actually current automobile models
don't know don't know how to do it it i
don't say they want we're working on it
but currently they don't so it's a
problem
it's limiting you on your ability to
develop cool new pipelines
uh they're not really good in picking
meaningful features so the feature
selection
part of the pipeline which you're
probably
spending most of the time of at least
like a decent portion of time am i wrong
okay so exactly thank you
deep learning guys and girls
okay it's like not here this is like the
classical stuff so
feature selection is hard you know that
and actually it's really hard even for
the computer and currently we're really
stuck in future selection again
trying to improve and finally we don't
have a background knowledge
okay and if as a guy that's working on
biology and clinical and stuff doctors
have a lot in their head they don't tell
you you need to extract it for them but
they have a lot of knowledge and if you
have the time and enough coffee to
extract this knowledge from them they're
actually really really good at telling
you like the right direction think about
it as a really good seed
like super good seed
er so
otama don't have it they don't have
enough time and coffee for and
convincing power on over clinicians
yet
so
how can we make autumnal better so there
are two main approaches nowadays the
first approach is let's search a ml
pipeline is better
everybody does it
everybody like sqln meta learning cool
let's start from a good seed running for
them cool teapot let's have a direct
search that's actually going like such
in the space a bit better cool like i
can continue in containers there are a
lot of packages a lot of ideas and many
papers for in the last i would say four
years
uh so we can search better and we are
searching better and it's great and good
for everyone er personally enjoying the
fact that people start in search
pipelines better but the other approach
is most of the time actually like have a
blind spot in people's heads it's funny
the important people says so if the
smaller databases can solve this so
think about the following idea you have
a big data set yeah which is great we
love big data sets everybody in the
market like i have 40 terabytes i have
four petabytes cool what do you i cannot
run for pet advice like maybe you can
but it's really expensive uh so can you
give me like i don't know 100 raw lines
that represent the data and the answer
is yeah take the first 100 but again
from the first presentation it's not
really good you have problems and we
already talked about them so can we do
it in a smart way
so the answer is uh we try to and i will
suggest one option and i try to convince
you this is a good one
but again you have
you have your computers you can try and
other options as well so think about the
following problem you have a database or
basically a matrix and i ask you to get
a subset of the matrix
okay so far so good but the idea is that
i want to preserve some measurements
some
goodness measurement if you want so in
our paper we actually used a mean
entropy
and just because
no to be honest we tried like 20
different types and i mean h2v was the
best one but in the pepper we said that
mean entropy is death now we just speak
it and it was really good
and you know how we write papers
nowadays so
we have a big subset of the data and the
only idea is that we want to find the
subset to maximize the mean and the mean
entropy distance from the mean entropy
of the real big data set okay
am i clearer so far
great
so this is actually really really hard
and we show you in a second how we do it
but the pipeline will go as follows so
we compute the really small data set
from the big one and a we employ the
otml tool which will be actually really
fast because it doesn't have to run on
one million rows and 50 columns and can
run on like 1000 rounds and six columns
it's it's an improvement you can see by
yourself
and now we actually have a really good
seed for the autoimmo
and actually when you're searching stuff
starting from the right position initial
position actually solve the problem most
of the time yeah think about it like
that if i need to go to the pizza and
i'm starting really close to the pizza
it will be relatively easy to get the
pizza how many potatoes i said pizza
okay great so this is the motivation i
get into intermediate ml pipeline
configuration and now i just fine-tuned
the restricted.terminal what i do i can
hyper parameters tuning i can feature
selection better in deep in this paper
we just find a hyper parameter tuning
and still get really decent improvement
which is showing how hyper parameters
are important and basically getting the
phantom automl
a pipeline
simplifying getting the final ml
pipeline from the autumnal without
spending too much time and i will give
you empirical stuff in a second
yeah
so
i promise to tell you how we do the cool
stuff so we're actually using
the genetic algorithm approach i already
said that my favorite one and the idea
is actually quite simple get a candidate
a candidate or gene if you want is just
a subset of the rows and the columns
okay
so far so good
take the gene and
i can explain in a second what all the
operations but
the basic idea is chat and check out his
main entropy it's really easy just take
like pandas take the rows the columns
calculate them in entropy i'll call them
in entropy ones of the first big data
set yeah don't compute it any time it
doesn't change believe me i tried er
same thing so
compute the l one l two and l infinity
whatever distance that you want and get
the result this is the fitness of the
gene or you can think about it is how
the gene is good okay the goodness of
the gin
and then the basic idea is
if you have a good gene you want to keep
it if you have the beijing you want not
to give it or basically if it's a good
genie can like
find
food and run out of predators and if
it's vegin it's being killed by the
predators okay so have this hostic
approach
do it enough times and it should be fun
okay and morty does in the paper or
you can ask me after the presentation
and finally you get a really good um
subset of the data is it the optimal one
no
it's a local optima and if you want to
provision a global optima you cannot
i tried at least no papers out there i
tried nobody's like doesn't work
nowadays if you can do it actually it
should be great paper please
post me
great
result
so okay it works on theory it sounds
great we get like local optima the idea
sounds like more or less fine at least
in this part of the room and
so we tried to take the ten different
data sets
everyone from cargill because you know
kagan
and a you can see that the number of
rows columns and the domain is
we try to be like as random as we can
you can see actually really challenging
data sets like
number d8
okay you see a lot of columns and a
small number of rows it's actually
called a course of divisionality it's
considered to be really hard to act
specifically for ml because optimal like
the classical autumnal solution designed
for more like the first row or the last
row a lot of a lot of rows and a small
number of columns
okay so actually number eight is a
challenging one number three is a
challenging one etc
yeah
so random data sets it's always a good
start
and
to be
as robust as we can we actually can
test out our algorithm um
when we compare it to a lot of other
algorithms so for example if you just
taken
the best a subset we take from 100 tries
so you just randomly pick the subset
you can do it 100 times and just the
best one between them is the
subset that you take or if you do it one
like 100 times
what what happened if you take it 24
hours
so it's a cpu bounded and not like
sample bounded and centered such a great
deselection motion banded er everybody i
guess you're all familiar with these
algorithms
the classical most of them
okay
and so
we tried our algorithm comparing which a
lot of algorithms and we try to do it in
two metrics as in parallel so one is the
relative accuracy
if we don't use a like minimizing
maximizing approach
and just running the autumnal on the
real data set which again really
expensive and how much accuracy do we
lose okay again you can say f1 is better
i know this kind of people a accuracy is
the standard so we use accuracy and the
second a metric is the time reduction
okay
basically we want to know how much time
we have saved relatively
okay
cool
so this is the results
so we can see a scatter plot on the left
uh showing we actually bonded the 95
percent because
a reduction of more than five percent in
the accuracy we thought it's like
doesn't make sense
it like okay which losing like one
percent of your accuracy two percent but
five percent it's just too much
okay at least in our heads you can move
the borrow as as far as you can i want
and the result is a yay move on so
subtract a actually reduces an 81 of the
communication time and actually you
suffer in around 1.3 percent of your
accuracy
it's not that much if you think about it
you're getting like a
eighty percent faster for like one point
three percent and it's relatively stable
like zero six in the standard deviation
between ten data sets so it's more or
less fine a teapot constantly getting
worse results we don't actually know why
uh but you can see it's just worse in
any way
um
so
this is one
and the question is can we actually do
something maybe we choose the wrong
number of rows we just changed the wrong
number of columns and something like
that so
um
actually we tried the loft
configurations this is the skyline plot
i we actually tested like 300
configurations
so we tested it out and we have
cool heat maps
because any good papers need to have a
heat map nowadays so
relative accuracy reduction as a
function of pros and cons
so you see we lose a lot of data when we
take a really really small subset
and we losing less data when we take it
longer okay so we have traders
same idea different plots
okay
uh so i just had to present him so he
made me promise to mention he's looking
for brilliant tennis page this isn't his
cohort or the author of the paper if you
messed up a standalone message that his
love is the best and you should drop him
a message okay
no it's a is fine
hey
they give you 30 seconds to
copy his number on etc
i think 30 seconds is fine
uh
and before you go in home slide
um okay so auto email is an amazing tool
but you're not production already yet
okay so
don't use watermelon like
i see too many clients of ours just say
yeah give me an automl i put it in
production he will get data and becoming
better over time like no he has a
concept directly it will get worse over
time don't do it um so it's it's not a
civil bullet it's cool if any you have
it as part of your development pipeline
for increasing the speed of your
development or
for poc sounds great for me but don't
use it in production not yet
you can either reduce the space of data
space or for demand tools okay so you
can actually play with the data domain
and you can play the search domain both
options are valid try both of them and
no free launch a faster computation
results in less accuracy
at least in our experiments
it's not a
mathematical proof
okay this is my details if someone
wants to have a chat
and that's it thank you very much and
yeah
this you said that you find you the
result of the language right how high do
i fine tune so i take you
the question is what is
the result of the 98 percent is after
[Music]
so i started it to a auto escalam er
which is really
auto like aoto s-k-l-e-a-r-n
and t-pot tpot okay so this is my two
favorites you have tons of them just
like right other ml like survey you see
like tens really hdo my friend really
likes it i think it's it's it's shitty
it's just too many configurations for me
i'm a math guy so too much code around
it yeah
so really a lot of them we have one
but it's not free
someone need to eat lunch here
any other questions
yeah if we do combination
do you make sure that you don't have
duplicate problems
specific cell yes
no you're muted at the wrong column
okay
you basically
you can i i skip it because i don't want
to get too detailed but basically gene
is a two vectors one the i indexes of
the rows and the second in the indexes
of the column so you don't control on
the cell level you control on the roller
and the column level
okay
so okay so this
now both of them you take a subset of
the rows and the columns this is the
trick if you just take a subset of the
rows it's like for the reduction subset
of the columns is feature selection and
so we we do it like a cool stuff in
between
cool is a like personal choice of words
you can call it whatever you want but
cool is a good choice
um great so have a nice evening and see
you next time